for people who don't know you have a
studio at chalice that you've had for
what four years three years about to be
four years in august that's where you
did racks in the middle right um racks
in the middle i did a bunch of stuff all
night all of the nice [ __ ] one kd2 magic
um yeah it's it's a special place man um
crazy we did burden the proof at
challenge too
i think i was i was there for that yeah
i was there for some of that [ __ ] conway
was there
yeah it's crazy west side gun it was a
yeah hey and unofficially the start of
the album we're never going to get the
freddie gibbs benny album that's
probably never coming out i hope it does
man if not we will leak we're gonna well
you already kind of leaked it well i put
it on my ig one day i was just playing
and i'm like this [ __ ] too hard people
gotta hear this
yeah yeah they leaked it on my joint you
took it down though i'll take it down
did anybody hit you about it i did get
hit up for sure it wasn't even like take
it down i just was like i'm gonna just
take it who hit you up about it
a couple people trouble people yeah
yeah from both sides yeah like yo what
the [ __ ] i thought about doing the same
thing i'm glad it was you though because
you made it i was like i can't do this
yeah and i was just like this be crazy
that song is insane mclovin hopefully it
comes out one day man maybe if you do
like a like it's on youtube and all that
for sure oh is it i mean just like a
leaked oh just your version that you put
you put up not the whole thing